like yeah if you want us if you want to
pre-buy southern sam's sticky icky you
need to just uh i don't know dm me on
twitter by my twitter is seanviewfeed
dmv and say i'm in on southern stan
sticky icky
all right before we get in the episode
we got to say something really quick
sean i sent you that thing to share so
if you go to sean or i's twitter profile
you'll see it or you go to
ratethispodcast.com
mfm it stands for my first million
mfm if you leave a review for us on
apple podcast we're going to select one
person or we slept in one person oh no
we're selecting six people and we're
going to give a grand to six different
people and we'll announce that winner in
a couple weeks
we're doing this
because
if we get more reviews in a very
particular amount of time and you get
more momentum you go up the charts and
if you go up the charts you get more
listeners or at least that's the
hypothesis so we're incentivizing
listeners we get more excited we our
egos grow and i know that's what
everybody wants so let's do it
yeah i just went to a conference today
um cody sanchez has gone for us to talk
and uh dude everyone listens it's pretty
fun
how was uh how was the conference she
has uh her brand is like contrarian
contrarian capital i think it is um
and so this was
the contrarian conference or something
like that
yeah and i love her and i love the
conference but i it was kind of silly
like in my head i was making a joke
because they had contrarian
um merch and they had like hundreds of
the same ones and i was like well if we
all bought this like that's
you know it didn't really work that you
know what i mean like uh
so anyway it was great though no she was
cool i asked i think there was probably
300 people i asked who listened i feel
like everyone
all their hands went up people were
talking about us they always confuse our
voices but we get that all the time
all right i love it and i was supposed
to go to that i didn't go
you went um
there's like a bunch of different
motivations people have for going to
these things what was your motivation
because some people would say oh going
to these conferences is kind of a waste
of time
and other people say no i love it i
network i learn things
i just want you because she's she's my
friend and it's near my house
and then in general because you've gone
to some of some of some other ones like
this like the podcast one you went to
recently or stuff in new york what uh
i guess give give people how you think
about this stuff uh because i think it's
good to have like a frame of like okay
this is why i go to these this is how i
go to them and this is what's come out
of it for me um i like meeting people
who i know on the internet that makes me
feel good and i also like going you know
i've paid money to go to some events
i've paid five thousand ten thousand
dollars to go to some events um because
i can meet one person and become a
lifelong friend with them and that pays
for itself but makes me happy so yeah i
don't mind going
yeah i do the same thing i kind of have
in my head um
i'm here to learn one thing like i want
to have one great idea like a truly
great idea maybe it's a tactic a
marketing idea
a realization of something i need to
change
or a new business idea a new whatever so
one great idea is my like bar and then
one great person if i do that it's worth
it that's like such a low bar
but um yeah but what's better what like
the the good part about that is then you
go hunting you you're saying i'm here to
make me one great person who's a great
person and if you're talking to somebody
who's not that great you're like all
right peace out i'm gonna go bump around
and see who else is here right
and same thing with one great idea you
can listen to a talk and you might
otherwise kind of zone out or say oh
this doesn't apply to me but if you're
just on the hunt for that golden nugget
the one great idea and it's like dude in
the eight hours of this event there's
gonna be at least one great idea um it
changes the way for me at least it
changes the way i i attend these things
yeah i agree i'm the same way and
speaking of great ideas
do we i want to talk to me about let's
go to these three news stories that you
want to go over because i actually yeah
i think you selected all three and
they're awesome they're awesome all
three are pretty good
so um all right so i have three you have
one let's start with yours you have one
that's about elon tweeting about the uh
elon tweeted something about giving away
six billion world hunger what i heard
was you tell me if this is correct my
wife told me this story she goes do you
hear you know somebody tweeted out or
there's a news story that said you know
these billionaires the elon's the
richest man in the world now if he you
know with six billion dollars he could
end world hunger
and then he replied to it he was like if
you could show me that six billion
dollars would end world hunger
i'll write the check now like i'll i
will happily do it just show me that
that's the case
and um so that's all i know about this
what did you oh you don't know what
happened after that okay so uh someone i
forget who maybe cnn said if the
billionaires would donate six billion
dollars we'd cure or end world hunger
elon like you said replied and goes and
his language was great he goes show me
how that will happen and i will sell
tesla stock right now to pay for six
billion dollars of this stuff and i
forget the exact title but something
like the head of you united was it uh
world hunger or united nations some like
official
international body the head said you
know better yet
you know elon just come and we'll show
you our processes and how we work and
elon said no sunshine is great uh
tell me in tweet form how this is gonna
help and where the money will go and i
will send you the money right now and he
goes you know this is just too
complicated to say over twitter and
um i think and i'm not like the biggest
elon nut hugger i think that this
totally made elon look great
these types of things should be done in
a very simple way where you can explain
what's happening you don't have to say
like um you know exactly but you could
say like you know 30 of the budget is
going to go to hire around 10 000 people
who we think can give out this much you
know whatever that is a good enough
answer and uh the guy didn't do it total
miss and when we were talking to big
clown guy uh natter a few days ago
he was explaining what he does and then
you go no no no this is what you do and
you explained it so much better and he
goes oh that's how i should always
explain it
everyone should have that skill that you
have and you could actually develop that
skill it is a skill it's not just a
talent and anyway this guy blew it and i
thought it was an awesome tweet thread
you know so two things one is on that
skill so how do you develop that i'll
give you two kind of unorthodox ways
that you develop it
the first is you gotta have
callers around you so like you
know the way i was like no no dude
that's way too complicated
uh most people just won't say that to
somebody and uh there's this great clip
i know you like uh you watch some joe
rogan as well as i do and this is a
great clip of brian callan who's one of
the kind of friends and the crew of joe
rogan and they're they're doing their
fight companion podcast which is where
they just watch the fight
and they're just shooting the uh
drinking and eating cheese and you know
drinking wine eating cheese and they
watch the fight and like i don't know
a hundred thousand or more people will
tune in
to like hang out with them while they
watch the fight even though the fight's
not visible on the screen that's just
how fun it is for them to hang out and
during this thing brian callan who's a
lifelong you know like comedian he's
kind of like a scrawny guy and joe's
kind of like a former martial artist
he's sort of like a meathead and the
other guy on there is an ex-pro fighter
so it's a bunch of kind of like bros
and um and brian is saying something he
goes brian's like oh man if somebody
ever tried that on me
bro you know i would you know what i
would do and they were like
and they just kind of moved on for a
second and then he's like and the guy
said it again like nobody really
addressed it and he's like he's like
he's like i would never let somebody it
would be it would be on
and then
joe's like right what are you talking
about
he's like why are you saying like
this he's like you know you don't you're
not gonna do anything first of all and
he's like he's like the problem brian is
that you hang out with people that will
let you say like this and he's like
you need to stop hanging out with
whatever type of people let you let you
get away with just saying things like
this and just you know letting it fly
and after that i just thought that was
hilarious and then i started noticing oh
there's some people in my life and i
call them you know the people who will
tell you there's food in your teeth it's
like
there's two types of people there's
people who will see it and not say
anything and then you know four hours
later you get home and you're like bro
what the hell i had spinach in my teeth
the whole time why didn't someone tell
me and then there's the person who will
cut you off about here you go you got a
little something in your teeth here and
you're like oh i'm embarrassed but
like the embarrassment was localized to
the moment and then you like saved
yourself from there that's a true friend
and so you want people around you that
will tell you when you're saying
something that just makes no sense
or is confusing or is like delusional or
whatever and they're just like what are
you talking about why are you saying
that you say stuff like this all the
time this doesn't make any sense or you
say stuff like this and honestly i think
you think that's really awesome but no
when other people hear that they don't
hear really awesome like we asked
people like that abreu who used to work
for us and we love he was explaining to
sean and i what his new business does
and he wrote this long paragraph and i
think sean goes uh i don't know what any
of those words you just said mean
and then he was like
i buy con i buy land but before paying
for it i hurry up and resell it to
someone else and make a profit it's like
okay great now i understand what that
means right yeah well actually the first
thing he said was bro i just wrote you
two paragraphs
and i didn't even have to address it
because he knows
if you wrote two paragraphs and i don't
know what you're what i don't know what
you do still
that's on you that's not on b
and so uh you know the the burden's on
the owner so
one thing is having people like that
around you the other thing is hanging
out with somebody who's good at it
and maybe you know hopefully for some
people listen as this podcast helps them
because i think we both do a good job of
explaining stuff without too much jargon
no you try at least and so the more you
hang out with people like that you'll
just naturally through osmosis like you
know this it'll just pick up it'll be
like a sponge it'll just come right into
you you'll just start getting better at
it because you've heard our voices in
your head all the time and so hang out
with people who do it like i have a
buddy uh suli who's great at this you're
really great at this ramone's really
great at this so like our best friends
all are really good at just
saying things for what they are in a way
that's simple and easy and fun to
understand and like so then you by nate
you know you'll naturally get good at it
speaking of friends what uh what did so
i was out to dinner with moyes the other
day and he made this comment about
casper he ends up tweeting it pretty
brilliant you want to talk about that i
do it can i say one thing about the elon
so so the guy from world hunger who's
like oh it's not that simple i can't
really break it down all right so that's
obviously a loss on their end but there
is a great example of a charity who does
this well so um have you seen what
charity water does for their like
accountability
because uh what elon said was the whole
thing i'll donate the money my only
thing is it has to be kind of like open
source and transparently accountable
where the money is going and what's the
effect of it jack dorsey did that as
well and he just jack dorsey did it with
a google spreadsheet
right yeah he said here's the here's all
the money
here's where it's going here's the
schedule and here's it's a google doc
it's a google doc that anybody can go
view
and you can't edit it but you can go
view it at any given time and see how
the money thing is amazing so so the
founder of cherry water he uh his
story's amazing but like i'll give you
kind of the the fast forwarded version
of it so fast forwarded version of his
stories a guy named scott harrison
he um
he grows up and when he's a kid his mom
got this like
um terrible illness she basically she
was a stay-at-home mom so the dad goes
to work kids go to school she stayed
home and the new house they had moved
into it had like a gas leak or something
like that and so it like silently killed
her autoimmune system so she got so uh
her immune system was so compromised
that she could not like go outside she
could not like touch objects that had
not been sanitized she couldn't do the
laundry because like the the cleaner the
bleach has chemicals in it and it would
just like kill her if you know they had
to like do everything by hand using
baking soda six times or like if she
wanted to read a book scott would go put
it in the oven first and they would have
to sort of like kill all the bacteria
like by sanitizing it with heat and then
hand it to her and she'd wear gloves and
they would like slowly turn pages and
stuff like that like it was insane
and so he um
but even that whole time they didn't sue
the company that had that was
responsible for the leak because they
were like very religious family and they
were like you know this is god's plan
and so scott who like grows up with this
really unusual childhood he's having to
like in many ways be the caretaker of
the household because his mom wasn't
able to do it he sees his mom's
suffering he's like dude you know
effortless religion i'm uh i'm
gonna go live now so he gets he turns 18
and he like goes to college but i think
i think he might have dropped out
not 100 sure but he he starts partying
like crazy he moves to new york
and he becomes like a guy in the party
scene and scott if you've ever seen him
he's a good-looking guy he's sort of
like a george clooney-looking
like he's like very like
it's like guy gets gray hair and he
looks even him more handsome than he did
before and so
super great storyteller really funny
just he's a great hang like
i've hung out with him and you're just
like charmed you know the whole time
and so anyways he's he hits the party
scene and he eventually he's like all
right i gotta make some money so he
becomes a party like promoter so his job
was and he says this like my job was to
convince rich guys that they needed to
pay me like five thousand dollars six
thousand dollars to get to go buy this
hundred dollar bottle of alcohol and
he's like they knew what they were doing
and i knew what i was doing and it
worked anyways and so
he starts making a killing as a party
promoter and he's got the fancy watch
he's got the model girlfriends he's got
the nice penthouse in new york and he's
getting paid you know whatever some
vodka company will pay him 2500 a night
just to be drinking their liquor instead
of somebody else's liquor and somebody
will pay him to wear this watch instead
of somebody else's watch and so he's
kind of the man in this scene
but a few years go by and he's like
starts to feel you know as you do when
you kind of get in this party lifestyle
he starts to feel a little empty inside
like the the high is no longer doing it
for you anymore and i think he was the
story is he was on this guy's boat this
guy
his name is
what is the name guy the guy who created
cirque du soleil like guy
canadian guy
some name like that i can't remember off
top my head billionaire canadian yeah
he's on his yacht or boat or whatever
party boat
and scott's just in the boat like in the
room where he was in there's a bible and
he kind of sees it and he grew up in a
super religious household and then has
you know become basically like a sinner
um and he just sort of picks up the book
and you know he's hungover one day and
he starts reading it he's reading the
bible and he starts to like kind of like
get emotional
and he sort of has this literal like
come to jesus moment where he's like
what am i doing with my life like you
know like i'm not a good person i'm not
doing good for anyone in the world
and like you know i'm just like partying
and drinking it's all a very shallow
lifestyle it's like you know
uh these these hot girls and then these
rich guys and this like lifestyle that's
not great drugs alcohol that sort of
thing
so he's like okay and i think also he
literally woke up that day and he was
like numb in his hand he's like this is
like a metaphor i'm not just numbing my
arm like i'm numb in life right now so
he's like okay here's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna take the next six months i'm
just gonna take a six month break from
this lifestyle and i'm just gonna what's
like the most servant
like servant thing i can go do how can i
just serve people you know how can i go
do a very christian thing here and um
and so he applies to all these
non-profits and they reject him they're
like you're a party promoter like
we don't he's like dude i'll work for
free
and they're like no we don't need you
you're kind here he's like are you sure
like i'm good with people i'm good with
like events i'm good with all this stuff
and they're like no no like where you
come from that's not that's not what
we're looking for here so he gets
rejected after one after another and
finally he gets this one group to agree
to let him work there if he pays so he
had to pay to go work there so he
basically made a large contribution to
um mercy ships i think is what it's
called
it's basically a thing where
hotshot doctors in the u.s like for one
week out of the year they go on this
boat and it goes to africa and then they
they spend all week there doing like uh
pro bono surgeries on people who need
surgeries and then they come back and
he's like he kind of his background is
photography so he's like oh dude i'll
i'll take photos of this trip
uh that'll be my contribution and so he
goes there and he's got the photos still
he'll show it to you and when he gives
us talk he shows them it's like what
they were doing was there was kids with
like uh massive like tumor growth so
like you know they would have like a
huge lump on the side of their head like
the size of a volleyball or like in
their jaw their jaw would be protruding
out like six inches because they had
this growth and like all they needed was
just for it to be removed like
they're having trouble eating breathing
it's like not even a cancerous thing
it's just a benign tumor but this needed
it removed and he's like dude the line
was like a mile long
and he's like the saddest part is we
um you know we couldn't do all the shirt
though the one week was up and there's
still people in the end of the line that
didn't get their surgeries or whatever
so he's like okay
um i'm not just gonna do this i i'm just
gonna like i'm gonna go back
i'm gonna dedicate my life
to like you know uh helping people
because i can't believe what i've been
doing and this was so meaningful to me
and whatever so he's like for he does
two things he goes to on the ground in
africa and he says what is the like root
cause what are some of the root causes
of this problem so he does kind of what
elon calls first principles thinking
which is why does this person have this
crazy tumor in the first place it's like
well
they might have this tumor because
um you know they are are they don't have
clean drinking water and sanitation and
so there's like highly infested things
so you found that on all these different
axes like why are these women uh why why
are women um you know falling so far
behind in society and not getting high
paying jobs well because they actually
have to spend five hours a day just
walking to the nearest waterhole and
walking back carrying this 40 pound 50
pound jug of water and that takes five
hours in a day and then then they have
to use that water quickly um and like do
all the laundry cooking washing of their
kids and then like they don't work and
then because of that they're like
you know stuck and economically stuck so
anyways he identifies waters the root
cause he's like okay and he asked
himself a very important question he
goes
why have i not been giving to charity
like i kind of knew
they're suffering all around the world
kids in africa are starving and need
water and all this why didn't i give and
it's a this is the connection to the
elon thing he's like because i always
kind of felt and heard like you never
know where the money goes or if you give
if you get even if you do give money um
you have this worry like i don't know if
this is even making an impact and they
never closed the loop so you never knew
where the money went and you never saw
the impact of your dollars it was just
like thank you goodbye here's your tax
here's your tax deduction goodbye and so
he's like all right i'm gonna do it
differently he's like he's like he
didn't know anything about the
non-profit space but he's like all right
let's just do the basics he's like
what if 100 of the money went to the
cause and he's like that would like
clear up that question mark he's like
and then he's like also i'm a
photographer like why don't we just take
photos of the place where we do the
project and send it to the person who
gave us the money like if you
contributed we know where the project is
why don't we just send you a photo when
we do the project and say hey here's
what you what you did
and he so he's like i'm going to use gps
trackers
and photos to make people feel the
effect of their giving and that's what
he does now that's what he does now so
he goes back to new york he throws a
party because he's like uh that's kind
of the only thing i know how to do if
he's like i'm throwing a party it's my
30th 30th birthday or something like
that he's like throw a birthday party
but instead of giving me a gift at the
door charge
i just want you to give 30 to the cause
i'm 30 years old give 30 bucks to the
cause and so people come they have this
party because he's got a great social
network in new york
and uh you know they forget about it
three months later he sent them all
photos
of the project that they contributed to
he's like hey that that all added up we
drilled these two water wells they used
to have to walk this far now here's how
far they walk look at the map
and um you know we turned a four-hour
walk into a you know into a 10-minute
walk and then he's like um here's what
the women have to say there's videos of
them thanking you and here's like the
kids you know here's the water like
fresh clean this is the water they used
to drink it's like dirty here's the
clean clear water that's what you did
and people were blown away and that
became the name
they raised a ton of money like 400 500
million dollars yeah well the story gets
a little crazier so he he's he's like
i'm going to stick to this 100 model 100
of money goes to the college and people
were like well bro there's a reason
people don't do that like how are you
going to pay for your own salary or the
salary of anybody working on the charity
he's like we'll do a separate bank
account literally two bank accounts one
that's public donations that go to the
cause and one that'll be private
donations for people that want to fund
our charity to do this
and he's like
and of course people are pretty
interested in doing the 100 thing unless
people were into the private thing and
that's where like kind of full circle uh
uh i guess like i don't know how long i
want to go on this but i'll give you the
kind of the cool the cool last bit so
he's basically running out of money
um for the private side for the actual
for himself and he's just sleeping on
couches and he's like you know i got a
backpack to my name and like i'm the
only employee so it's fine
and but even still he starts running out
of money his friends are kind of kicking
him off couches he's running out of
friends houses to go sleep in
and he's like all right um he's like let
me just do what like this whole thing
may end but i want to do as much good as
i can in the meantime so he's like you
know this birthday idea of giving up
your birthday like we're all pretty
privileged we don't need birthday gifts
i gave up my birthday that's how i
started this charity like instead of
giving to me give to them um he's like
dude there's these social networks now
facebook myspace bibo that they all have
like millions of people and they all
have this birthday feature people go
right on each other's wall he's like so
he wrote a letter to mark zuckerberg
to like tom from myspace and to michael
burch from bibo and he wrote a letter to
all of them he said hey you have
millions and millions of members on your
platforms they all have birthdays log
registered in the platform and people
looking for a way to wish each other
um it would be amazing if you added a
charity button a way for you to give up
your birthday and let people donate for
your birthday to the cause um he gets no
reply from facebook he gets no reply
from myspace and he gets no reply from
bebo
so he's like uh whatever didn't work now
a month later michael burch from bebo
says hey scott sorry i missed this uh we
actually just sold the company so he
just sold the company for 850 million
dollars and he said uh you know so i
can't really implement this here but you
know what i'm in new york uh let's just
meet up for an hour
and so he goes and he meets with him
scott gives him the full pitch michael's
like a british guy he's pretty reserved
you know in person he's he's you know
british people have like a dry sense of
humor too so they're not like
the most like emotive when you're
talking to them and so scott basically
said feels like oh i told this guy what
we're doing he basically didn't flinch
and he moved on like whatever
and um he had six weeks of runway left
in the bank he's like ah that was my
last that was my hail mary i have six
months six weeks of runway left and then
this whole thing ends but you know what
we did some good work
and then michael wrote him an email
right after the meeting like the next
day and he just said hey scott loved her
chat
um
send me your wire instructions i'll send
you a million dollars use it however you
wish keep rocking
and the million dollars kept them going
for one more year and then since then
they've now raised hundreds of millions
of dollars for the charity they're like
one of the biggest privately backed
charities because they have this 100
model and michael got them in with other
kind of wealthy tech people and they all
like this idea of like accountability
transparency and closing the loop on on
giving and feeling the impact like that
just feels right to the kind of the new
new wave of rich people and so it's like
taking off since then that's the crazy
story of charity water
that you just gave them a 30 minute
infomercial
yeah uh i don't feel bad i've been with
them to africa and literally it's like
uh it's not only like changing lives but
when when he goes there people literally
he's the most humble dude but i went to
the village and people literally feel
like he's jesus
hey because it's like a white man who
comes to this village he's like the only
white person ever like in the village
and b because he like whatever he's
doing when he leaves here somehow
results in fresh water being like given
to our village and they're like thank
you whatever you're doing out there is
is you know god's work that's badass i
should i should give to him i have not
but
after that pitch i will um can i let me
tell you about someone interesting have
you heard of a guy named aj patel i bet
you haven't
never heard of him what is it
you have not heard of him and you're
going to be surprised that you've not
heard of him so this guy's way low-key
and i got interested in the space
because i've been a lot really
interested in low sugar products
uh
whenever like whenever i'm in new york
or particularly new york because i go to
like corner stores all the time you see
like
moms with their kids and they buy like
hawaiian punch or like gatorade
like a sugar factory a corner store and
a grocery store are sugar factories it's
sad and i feel horrible dispensaries
maybe yeah it's horrible and it's
because maybe that's just more
convenient but and people just i don't
think know better so i've been doing
research and i found this guy named aj
patel so
listen to what this guy's done so he
started a this he's only 32. so he
started this thing called smooth viking
which was a men's grooming business that
he sold then he started in insta
naturals which is a
natural base skin care uh business it
did 55 million dollars in 2018 um and
it's been uh i mean it it crushes it um
and then he started zen wise which was
plant-powered vitamins and supplements
and it was doing okay like five to eight
million dollars in revenue but then he
was like the thing about vitamins like
people are a lot a lot of people are
asking me for vitamins for my pet for
their dogs for their cats and he was
like that's cool and it's even cooler
because you have no idea if it works
right that's the funny thing about pet
stuff and and i give my uh pet vitamins
and i'm like does it work i have no
idea right but i'm doing it and
so he starts this thing called zesty
paul's and zesty paul's is kind of
amazing and so he kind of creates a
strategy where he does two things the
first thing that he does is he spends a
lot of money up front on making the
brand really good you know a lot of guys
a lot of times guys like you or me will
just kind of throw something up there
yeah like an mvp right the minimum
viable product kind of looks shitty and
crappy at the beginning
yeah so he hires a a a agency or a
branding agency and they help him make
zesty paul's like look really great and
then he his whole goal is to first
dominate amazon then go to retail and i
was doing some research and i used uh
jungle scout and i also watched a bunch
of videos so zesty paul's recently sold
for 610 million dollars it's estimated
on amazon they are doing around 800
sorry 8 million dollars a month on
amazon only and then probably another
seven million uh through their retail
outlets it costs around eight dollars to
wholesale and it sells for twenty six
dollars so it they could have been doing
around forty million dollars in profit
when they sold and they sold for six
hundred and four uh ten million dollars
now the reason i'm bringing this up his
new thing it's called high key cookie
it's and i've noticed that when you look
up high key co-founder they'll want
they don't mention his name he's trying
to hide it for some reason i don't know
why he's trying to hide i don't know
what his deal is he just prefers being
low-key um but he doesn't talk about it
too much i think he just prefers being
low-key but uh high key is basically low
sugar cookies and he's doing the exact
same thing where he's getting on amazon
and he's ranking and he's got 60 000
reviews and it's a pretty new
product already it's pretty amazing what
this guy's doing he's doing the same
strategy over and over and over again um
are you looking at uh high key cookies
on i'm on his uh his linkedin right now
so he's listed as the co-ceo
and uh he looks like he's in florida how
did you hear about this person
um
i two different ways i was researching
um low-carb cookies because
i'm fascinated by that i'm right now
some current obsessions are low sugar
cookies and low sugar ketchup and other
sauces right um
and i was researching and i saw high key
and i remember a friend our mutual
friend told me about this guy who had
this thing called zesty paws and his
whole strategy was to dominate amazon
and then go to retail
wow
very impressive uh very few people have
done what this person has done so i
think he's 32 years old or 31.
yeah that's pretty impressive um have
you tried fat snacks it's like um
so i'm i have a list of lists here of
companies that are interesting and i did
try fat snacks and i thought that they
were fine i thought they were okay but
the problem that i have there so i eat
quest all the time are you familiar with
quest bars
yeah
i like the quest chips because i'm a
chip guy i don't have a sweet tooth but
the quest
they basically have like a version of
doritos
and honestly they're like the only
keto snack that i actually
like
i'm like
it like actually replaces the craving
you know
yeah so i eat a ton of quests now but
there's like a big background here so uh
how do you say his last name tom bilyeu
he spoke at our event hustle county
pretty cool guy
this was actually one of the first d2c
kind of home runs so basically they
bootstrapped this company and within
five years sold it for a billion dollars
and they were making it i think tom's
mom or someone in his family was really
overweight and he wanted to create a low
light glycogen food you know lower carb
food for his overweight family member
and he's like i just need it to taste
good so we can replace candy and so he
creates this thing and revenue is
doubling like every month and eventually
they sell it
for a billion dollars when they get to
100 million in revenue but there's a
it's quite controversial so i eat them
but a lot of people don't like it
because it has sucralose or is that how
you pronounce it sucralose yeah that's
right and it's basically
like a sugar alcohol and they also put a
lot of fiber in it and so their protein
a lot of people don't like it because
it's like not the best protein it also
has palm oil a lot of people don't like
palm oil so a lot of like health nuts
including justin mares who i talked to
about this they don't like it because it
just kind of got some in there but
frankly i love it but um the reason why
quest bars are amazing is because they
are in every store if you go to
a 7-eleven or a gas station they're
gonna have quest bars right whereas a
lot of the other stuff the reason why i
don't consume as much as they're not
they're just not convenient right and so
anyway i'm getting incredibly fascinated
with these low sugar products that are
in every store well i like the idea of
the low sugar sauces i think low sugar
ketchup is a great one to go after who's
doing that is that is that a business
that's like saturated or no it's not a
vessel that's a great idea
i think it's fantastic and the reason
why it's fantastic is when you're trying
to eat lower carb and eat healthy
mustard has no calories and no sugar in
it barbecue sauce is uh ketchup
very high sugar you know if heinz uh
heinz has a 45 billion dollar market cap
they make something like seven billion
dollars a year just in sauces and
condiments most of it is basically
ketchup and ketchup is crazy high sugar
their ketchup the reason why it's that
bright red is there's a ton of um
a ton of sugar in it and there's a
company called primal kitchen which sold
for 300 million dollars in 2018 it was
started by this guy who kind of looks
like an old version of me his name's
mark uh what's his name mark sisson i
think his name you have to look up mark
sisson
s-i-s-s-o-n i believe that's his name um
and he had a whole line dude just does
look like an older version of you that's
hilarious yeah he looks like an amazing
he's ripped this guy i don't know how
old he is he looks like he thinks he's
like 70s 60s yeah and he is like
absolutely shredded which is impressive
well i meant his face we kind of like
similar faces but older
dude this guy is this is you man this is
going to be amazing wow you're going to
look like this
so he's 68 years old
wow
crazy and so he had this
this business where he he had a blog
he's been a blogger forever a health
blogger and he created primal kitchen
which is a uh
uh they make dressings dude the
dressings and ketchup are the worst
dressings have some like an italian
dressing so much sugar oh i'm
eating a salad it's like how's the salad
like 1200 calories because the dressing
so i've been like super curious about
this and tell me what you think about
this the problem with a lot of d2c
companies is that the cost to acquire a
customer is stupidly high
right now it's i think it's the highest
it's ever been uh everywhere
the highest it's ever been yeah correct
but particularly with the facebook
change and competition it's just getting
high
so our friend andrew created this thing
where basically he he this was illegal
what he did but like whatever it
happened he he created a menu and put it
on ubereats and was just like making low
glycemic muffins so i guess like almond
flour muffins at home
and putting it on ubereats and he just
like made the branding really cute
could you just create like one of these
high key or these low carb cookies or
something like that and just put it on
the local ubereats start getting
customers put like a coupon code in
there i mean i feel like that's an
interesting way to kind of hack customer
acquisition for a lot of these d2c
things yeah i think that is kind of
interesting although i don't know how
many people are gonna like order just uh
like even a bakery it's like okay yeah
you're getting like you know a dozen
muffins or cookies or whatever like i
don't know if people would just go order
um like a sauce or something right like
this
no but the cookies
yeah i don't think they would do cookies
but have you heard of some insomnia by
the way it's only illegal because he
just didn't have a commercial
commercial kitchen and a license right
but like you could easily do that right
you could do the same exact thing if
you're just if you're not doing it out
of a you know like a home kitchen or
whatever you just need a permit right
that's the only problem with it yes
correct have you heard of insomnia
cookies
yeah they're insane
yeah they're insane they're amazing i'm
just thinking like i think you could do
that from a cloud kitchen and then start
selling them online
i totally think you do that crumble is
also like growing like crazy right now i
think it's one of the fastest growing
franchises is crumble cookies
um but let's get back to this ketchup
idea how do i convince you to start this
company because you would crush it uh
it's in your area of expertise it's a
beautiful market because huge like huge
demand um and it's a consumable so you
run out and you have to keep re
re-buying
um and people use a lot of sauce and you
could turn this into a whole you can
extend into other sauces but if you'd
start with you know ranch or you start
with ketchup you'd get like a huge
number of people barbecue sauce like
just two three skus you could do this
and then with your marketing prowess
like you could build you could literally
build like a 500 million dollar company
for this in like four years uh i think
it's amazing
to me i i should the other day i went to
the store and i bought ketchup i the
other day i went to the store and i
bought ketchup and it was it was like a
hot i didn't realize it was near
halloween and they called it blood
tomato and i thought that meant like oh
like it's like it's a weird category
where it's only the tomatoes and no
sugar and i bought it and it was just
normal hinds and i've been eating this
all week because i don't want to
throw it away and it's horrible the
sugar in heinz is is it makes it taste
good
so sam sauce what are we calling uh what
do we call the the the brand here
southern sticky icky yeah
yeah there we go dude
yes
there we go
oh my god dude southern sam is such a
good i'm not joking like okay
i'm just gonna use you as the face of
this i'll build the bread i'll do all
the work maybe and actually we'll watch
this thing
dude this is an incredible you're like
sticky icky like yeah if you want to if
you want to pre-buy southern sam's
sticky icky you need to just uh i don't
know dm me on twitter by my twitter is
seanviewfeeddmv and say i'm in on
southern
sticky icky which is this first sauce
that's coming out and it's gonna be a i
mean you're a fitness influencer so you
gotta have
that balance you're gonna have the
health aspect we know that we've seen
the body we've seen the videos what we
need now is that flavor
but southern sam
he's been
this is what you needed back when you
had your hot dog stand you just needed
the condiments
you just needed a it's a full circle
oh my god i love it have you heard of um
sir kensington ketchup
yes my buddy
our buddy invested in it who
um
oh okay great it sold for uh 140 million
dollars
yeah and i think it undersold
it sold pretty you know sold early on
yeah but i think at that time also like
i think selling helped them get into
retail in a big way
and uh you know that's one of the good
things about selling these companies is
like if you could do the branding you
could do the cult online following you
can do the d2c online marketing side
you actually almost want to leave some
dry powder
for the acquirer you want to go to the
acquirer and say yeah we're doing
amazing and we have we don't even know
how to do retail you guys know that
right you guys know you got you got a
buddy you play golf with who does target
who does uh
safeways nationwide on the you know you
have the the guy in the rocky mountain
region for whole foods he's your ex frat
buddy oh fantastic like
you should just buy this and then boom
you already have your growth story baked
in of how you're going to improve this
and so that actually helps you sell the
companies to have that dry powder of
sure what can the acquirer do they don't
want to see a lemon that's just been
squeezed all the way all the juice is
out because then it's all priced in
dude maybe i'll go to the store like
right for this just go buy a bunch of
organic and low sugar ketchups and see
what's out there
like i'll be the first to admit the
sugar in there makes it taste so good i
mean i'll just eat ketchup with a spoon
that's just so good this is the idea
okay
okay okay i got full last episode it was
like uh what can we do with this
marketing budget that will uh like make
for a good story beyond just you know
direct response ads
this is what we should do with the
marketing budget we should be launched
showing we'll do case studies basically
do a fully open business basically we
should show how we would build this
business from scratch and southern sam's
southern sam's secret sauce is gonna be
the first place that we start we just we
take we take 10 grand we take 10 15
grand and we put that instead of going
and saying hey listen to our podcast we
actually just tell the story of how
we're building this on the podcast and
that will make people want to tune in
they'll see the growth and they'll see
the success story which is ultimately
what this podcast is about brainstorming
great ideas and then talking about how
you bring how you would bring them to
life it's definitely interesting i think
it'd be fun i got to go to the store
though and buy a bunch of them and see
what they're about and see if they taste
good but uh this primal kitchen one
seems incredibly interesting
i and i would imagine that these
i bet
the multiples for selling these
i would imagine they'd be all right
right they'd be pretty good because
the repeat purchase rate on ketchup is
crazy high i'd have to imagine
yeah i think you can safely sell for you
know somewhere between 2 and 4x revenue
depending on what your story is so how
fast you're growing how big that market
is you know et cetera et cetera but i
think two even up to five times uh
revenue is possible for a brand like
this but yeah well then i'm only going
off a couple of data points maybe those
were outliers that i know about i'm not
sure yeah i'll go do some research i'm
gonna figure out i'm gonna i'm going
after the big ketchup
yeah exactly we're going after big red
we're gonna have to we're going after
big sugar
but
i also think uh maybe maybe a gum line
how about gum do you like gum sugar
most gum is sugar-free
you know it's like the best sugar-free
gum it's better than scripting
we have to go to the next level we have
to be like xylitol free or due to
trident remember
remember how trident is like dentist
recommended that's been sugar free
yeah well we are all
recommended we're selling choose gum if
anything you're gonna do gum with
caffeine in it
there's this guy named there's this guy
named nick simmons he's got this
business called run gum and it's gum
with caffeine in it
lucy doing is that what that is yeah so
i invested in a nicotine uh gum company
i think it's only doing okay gotcha dude
i love nicotine though i i i here let me
show you what i have in my pocket right
now
can you see this
uh i see it's a little fuzzy but i see
like a vial of some kind what is that
it's nicotine lozenges
and it's just it's just like a cough
drop
you just put it in your lip and you just
kind of suck on it i love nicotine man
is that the same thing as a pouch
no there's no tobacco there's no tobacco
it's just it's literally just like a
mint it's like a mint that has negative
that does what why do you do that to
stop to quit smoking or to give you a
bun yeah so like i like cigars and so if
i could i would smoke cigars all day and
so now i can go like two three weeks
without a cigar and i just like
sucking on these things i feel like
nicotine does have a lot of interesting
advantages and i don't i don't know if
nicotine is inherently bad for you in
itself i know that the tobacco is
so i bumped into this guy
on twitter and go to
um
go to it's oklahoma or just just google
oklahoma smokes have you heard of this
brand
no but i love it
so oklahoma smokes almost like a sister
brand to southern sam sticky icky but uh
oklahoma so so this guy was like oh yeah
i have this uh like agency
and we were doing kind of like branding
for other products and then we launched
our own product uh oklahoma smokes and
it's basically it's an alternative
uh thing you could smoke it's like an
alternative cigarette
and it's got no nicotine and no tobacco
but it's got the form factor of a
cigarette so you light it up you smoke
it you puff it out whatever
and um
and it's doing really well so he's got
like a good amount of traction and i was
like wow uh that's great like you know
what's uh
and so i looked him up in the kind of
like ad library and i was like dude i
don't see any ads he goes oh yeah you
can't advertise for this on uh facebook
or like pretty much any ad network
because they don't want you advertising
cigarettes even though this is like a
nicotine free tobacco-free and um he's
like so it's all just organic like
tick-tock basically people just post
about it on tik-tok and it goes like
kind of viral on tick tock and that's
where all the growth comes from it's
just people organically talking about it
on tick tock
and they have a slick website
the website is very nice the branding is
great
um
the whole thing is really well done um
and i i like it a lot so you know
oklahoma smokes maybe we work with their
agency for our uh for our brand all
right we got who they use it's all
coming together they are the agency
that's what they were doing
are they based in oklahoma
no i think it's just a brand like the
dude was like just like some indian dude
although i'm an indie dude i was born in
oklahoma so i guess i guess maybe they
do have some oklahoma roots i'm not sure
but i think it's a lot more like where
do they live isn't this just like isn't
that an amazing brand name oklahoma this
is amazing
oklahoma just sounds like a band
i want to wear this
like everything i want to be a part of
yes
oklahoma smokes oh that's phenomenal
that's a brilliant name right like if
that was my nickname you know i'd be a
happy man so and they're doing here's
their dude look at this company they're
doing no nick november so no nicotine
november
uh and they're giving you discounts um
september baby
this is good i like these guys where do
they live do you know
uh i have no idea i don't even know if
he wanted me to shout it out i mean he
probably is happy with it but uh i've
never tried it i don't smoke so it's
like not a product i would use i just
thought the branding was extremely well
done and so i kind of added it to my
swipe file of like oh this is this is a
great name and a great brand here and uh
really cool product idea and challenging
you know it's it's doing well but it's
not huge because very hard to grow very
hard to market something like this um
through traditional channels so i don't
know what they're going to do
you know hopefully this gives them a
little spike or whatever but uh you know
i think that's the hard part about a
business like that
you want to do one more
um yeah let's do one more do you have
one or you want me to to pick one here
you we didn't do our news thing i kind
of hijacked it let's long ass chris
harrison pick one of those
pick one of the two
uh let's do the zillow thing so
so the funny story about this zillow
thing so zillow came out and they said
hey we are shutting down our ibuyer
business which is basically where they
would just
uh you want to sell your home boom we'll
give you an instant offer our algorithm
will do a calculation and spit out a
price you don't have to go through a
broker you don't have to stage your
house you don't have to do like three
months of showings like we'll just give
you an offer today you can sell your
home today and the idea was this was you
know sort of an idea they stole from
open door so open door was a startup
that was built to do just exactly this
instantaneous
uh like instant sales of houses
and um zillow saw open door growing and
value and now open doors public and they
created a couple years ago their own in
house like competitor
they copied that feature
but it didn't work so they got stuck
they just came out and announced hey we
lost 500 million dollars this quarter
oops uh we're going to lay off 25 of our
staff
and we have 7 000 homes that we need to
unload because we're getting out of this
business
and
they're getting 1.8 billion
they're getting out of it because they
also are getting criticized constantly
because
zillow is what everyone uses to
get comps for homes and if the person
also buys them you could easily
manipulate the price of things so if you
they can buy a home in one neighborhood
knowing that it's going to increase the
the
a lot of different things so and it's
competitive with their core business so
they're
which i give them credit for because
most companies they wouldn't do it for
all these reasons we're mentioning right
now they would just stay out and they
would get disrupted zillow tried to not
get disrupted decided to add this
feature but like their core business is
basically selling to agents
right for consumers they give you price
information and you're supposed to be a
trusted source so that's one challenge
the other conflict was
the main business is agents buying leads
from from zillow and if zillow is the
buyer then they don't need the agents
they are their own agent and so they
were competing with themselves in many
ways so anyways you're getting out of
this business uh you know big kind of uh
uh what do you call it like a scar from
like you know a bruise from from going
after this the stock price is just in
the which is ironic because
we're in this group chat where for
months like the last year basically
these guys have been our friends have
been like pimping out oh dude zillow
zillow's brazil is a great boss yeah and
i was like 25 000 worth exactly same i
bought i don't know like 50 or 100
dollars worth of it and i'm down big
everybody everybody in the group is
gonna be for something yeah we're all
down like somewhere between 30 and 40 or
something on this and i agreed with it i
thought so i think zillow's the greatest
thing ever because to me like what do
you do when you're in a fancy
neighborhood even if you're not buying a
home you just go into zillow you know
it's a category owner they own it right
yeah so so you know zillow the stock is
down big right now uh the funny thing is
open door stock also took a beating
so they're down like 12 just on the news
that zillow failed at this people are
like maybe opendoor's also gonna fail
with this and then they came out with
this god-awful did you see this tweet
that they did um
that that open door did it's the worst
it's the absolute tone-deaf idiot just
you know what the best thing to do is
make fun of them so listen you know what
do you remember what biden did when uh
he was running for president
which part forgetting he shut the
up because when you have the basement
yeah when you have a guy like trump who
does all the talking and like is his own
worth sending me you shut up you hide
and you don't say a word
that's what open door should have done
they should have locked themselves in
the basement and said everyone is
forgetting to mention us even though we
do this exact same thing you just shut
up
um and that's what they should have done
yeah or they should have come out cocky
they should have come out and posted a
chart of how much ass they were kicking
and just be like uh you know
this is you know this does this is a
hard business or it's not for everybody
and then just post their chart of
themselves kicking ass at the same time
zillow's dying on the same business but
instead i'm going to read this word for
word you tell me if you understand one
percent of this
open door just randomly tweets yesterday
we're in the midst first don't say midst
we're in the midst of a generational
shift towards a fully digital experience
comma with large comma unmet need for
seamless experience in real estate
period what a circle jerk said nothing
then
they reply to their own tweet with our
track record of executional excellence
and many years of investment and
consumer experience technology pricing
there's they're just saying words comma
technology comma pricing comma and
operations comma we are well hyphen
positioned to me consumer demand with a
best comma
in class product and service
open door is open for business we have
demonstrated strong growth unit
economics we are energized to help
homeowners nationwide with simplicity
certainty and speed
i saw this and i was like what the
the funny part the ironic part is this
is done by somebody who's like
they're calms their job is coms
corporate comms they're a communication
professional this is their their actual
job you want to know they forgot the
number one most important rule for about
copywriting you know what that number
one rule is
no one cares about you they only care
about themselves exactly that's the
number one rule if you remember that
you're gonna be you're gonna be 90 of
the way there no one cares about you
they only care about themselves it's
like when you go to a website and they
go we've been in business since 1994.
our pure our passion is to serve you our
dear customers we've been serving
customers for a long time and we know
that we're going to have a lot of high
integrity when we handle you it's like
i don't care
no one cares no one cares
yeah exactly
they violated all the rules so what's
another rule um
don't use words like that yeah exactly
you just talk like you speak talk like
you speak uh write write like you speak
and then use like you know eighth grade
reading level you know this is like you
know 20th grade reading level and i said
none of it none of it makes sense to the
average person uh they also didn't say
anything of interest like what did this
mean this all this meant was please
don't sell our stock please don't sell
our stock please please please please
don't sell our stock
we didn't make the mistake they did and
there were so many better ways to do
this so that was i thought so i think
there's this idea so like when i um was
running the show basically at the hustle
um
my staff would be like we need to change
the landing page or
we need to change the footer and i'm
like well why and they go well because
it's been the same forever and my
analogy was always yeah but you're
thinking about it this kind of poorly
for example our office was on a corner
and there was a billboard right there
and i would say how many people do you
think are going to see that billboard
for
many many times in a row and they would
say well most people are probably just
passing by and i go yeah i would agree
with that now of course you and i we've
been sitting here for a month now and we
see that same billboard every single day
so we're kind of sick of it but nine out
of 10 people are just passing by and
they're seeing it for the first time
every time what you need to remember is
that most people are not just sitting
there they're just a parade you know
walking by and that's what like open
door kind of like realize they're like
oh well yeah most people like so they're
probably in the thick of this and
they're seeing zillow flip out and
they're like everyone is everyone's
talking about this everyone's thinking
about us it's like no no no no you are
but most people don't give a
just shut up just be quiet hi
now's the time to hide
yeah so yeah i saw that and our friend
did something pretty funny
yeah so moyes uh mois ali he
um
he tweeted he tweeted out i love this
tweet by the way this is just he's very
he's a very good writer a great cocky
tweet so he goes dear zillow and rich
barton the ceo zillow who by the way is
badass um
i'm sure today is a tough day i'd like
to purchase all the homes you have on
your balance sheet in one transaction is
that something you'd consider i will pay
cash and closes in 30 days no
contingencies are financing delays best
comma m
signing off with the initial is the
power move by the way
i will never ever write my full name
again
because the initial is so good
and uh this is great obviously he's not
gonna buy 2.8 billion dollars uh worth
of stuff himself but but maybe
maybe uh maybe maybe he's got some
strategy here maybe he's got some money
he could tap into i'm not
sure but yeah it also just like
hilarious tweet and a way to kind of be
out there on twitter and ride the ride
the wave of something happening
yeah i thought this tweet was brilliant
he's a troll and i love when he trolls
because he trolls in a very smart way
yeah um he's a cocky troll and you know
the the weird thing is how did they lose
money doing this so like
the
from what i can tell they're like single
family homes which is what they were
buying seeing a family home market is
like at an all-time high like people
from covid are you know there was the
great reassessment which is what
happened during cove but everybody
reassessed their job their you know can
i work from home oh wow i didn't need to
travel for business i could just do a
zoom meeting and actually it works do i
need a gym membership i could work out
at home i could do i like this job or
actually maybe now that i have this
break i can i can think about what i
really want to do and i pick up this
hobby and you know maybe when i'm at
home in this marriage this marriage
sucks you know maybe i should reassess
that it was the great reassessment
and
during that a lot of people move they
move for different reasons if your job
is remote you could leave high priced
places like california and new york you
could relocate to other places um if
you're at home all the time maybe you
need more space and you want to
buy you want to buy a bigger bigger
place with a bigger yard and bigger
office space or whatever
so people were buying more than ever and
they were buying single-family homes so
people were leaving the cities and so
condos were down in inside san francisco
and new york um like 15 and
single-family homes were up 15-20
so i don't fully understand i'm sure
there's a totally logical explanation
but you know it's like how did you how
did you lose money
doing the one thing that everybody
wanted you were buying and selling
single-family homes like and i think
what they said was you know the price
was too unpredictable um
so we you know we weren't able to do
this well and the other thing they said
was
there's a labor shortage they couldn't
get people to come flip the home so like
do the repairs you needed to to flip the
homes um so yeah i'm sure like that's
really hard but that's crazy they
weren't able to do it in like a bull
market yeah i think it's nuts
it doesn't make me like them anymore and
i and i
i'm a shareholder i'm bummed i guess i
guess they should have just stuck to
what they did
you can hold your stock are you gonna
sell
i don't sell so yeah i'm gonna hold okay
cool me too um all right anything else
you wanted to do or we can wrap it up
here we'll wrap it up here um
don't forget to go to what was the url
uh rate thispodcast.com
mfm as in my first million so rate this
podcast go leave us a review if you if
you get enjoyment on the show that's
kind of all we ask helps us move up the
charts helps us get more downloads
i think we're going to do one more thing
i believe what we're gonna do
i'll kind of like
i'll say briefly um i think we wanna do
something where you get
we're gonna have a budget of like up to
20 grand a month
and the people who create clips for us
sean and get the most views we'll give
them a little bit of money
ah okay i like it yeah
banner jonathan came up with that
okay i like it yeah i paid to listen so
it's a good deal well you paid to chop
up clips and and to be creative so kind
of a good idea
all right all right that's the pod